- On this episode, we talk
Peach, we talk interruption
and value, and we talk
new year's resolutions.
(hip hop music)
You ask questions
and I answer them.
This is the #AskGaryVee Show.
Hey everybody, this is
Gary Vay-ner-chuk and this is
episode 174 of the #AskGaryVee Show.
I'm a little salty.
I'm supposed to be recording
my audio book right now,
there was some calendar mixup.
Not sure, haven't gotten to
the bottom of it just yet,
doesn't really matter, spilled milk.
Not interesting in dealing with it.
Moving forward, taping the show.
Actually you'll see the
moment where I found out there
was a mix up, as DRock
is doing DailyVee 004.
Super meta, it is what it is.
Tyler's tying to figure
out my phone there.
Do a little Snapchat while we're doing it.
India looks super ready.
- I'm super focused today.
- Let's just do it, let's just do it.
I'm ready.
- [India] Okay, cool.
- [Voiceover] MJG asks,
"Do you set personal
"and business goals for a new year?"
"If so, how do you stay
focused throughout the year?"
- I do not.
I have one business goal which
is to buy the New York Jets.
Really, my business goal
there is to have the game of
trying to buy the Jets.
I do set personal goals,
they come ad hoc.
You know, I started taking
care of my health in July,
not in January.
So, I don't.
I understand why people
do, it's a fresh start,
makes sense.
Whatever works for you.
I keep myself in check by
talking to myself often.
I probably communicate with
myself more than most people.
It's not like, "Hey Gary,
hey Gary," any kind of weird
or silly or interesting stuff.
It's just I think a lot.
I ponder a lot.
I check myself if I'm happy
or focused or what have you.
So I don't do anything in the new year.
Though, I tend to do things in a new year.
So I'm sure this Snapchat
hustle has a little bit
to do with the new year.
But, no I do not.
- [Voiceover] Kevin asks,
"You are incredibly passionate
"about Snapchat now.
"Snapchat's been around
a few years, why now?
"What's changed?"
- Kevin, I've done this a lot.
I did this with Instagram, as well.
I only get really loud in my
career when I think things
hit that moment when we're
just a year away from
mainstream.
I'm in love with the moment
when something's much bigger
than people realize mainstream.
Right before I went on to do
this show right now I just
retweeted that the White
House went on Snapchat.
Which I think has always been
a symbolic kind of thing.
Media for other things.
I have had a good understanding
of consumer behavior.
A website in 1996, email marketing in 97,
Google ad words.
Starting a YouTube show.
People are just ri--
I bet you could Google right
now why starting a YouTube
show is a good idea.
I did that 10 years ago.
Twitter, changed the course of my career.
I wrote a book called Crush It!
that basically speaks
about everything that's
going on right now on YouTube
and Vine and Instagram and Snapchat.
The reason I'm passionate
now is even though two years
ago I was like, "This
Snapchat thing is gonna win,
"the numbers are there."
This is the moment right now
where I see that window of
12 to 18 months to
really land grab at scale
before the whole market
comes along and tries to
do the same.
I believe that that's why so
many of the people watching
this show and watching my
content are gonna win.
Many people that were already
paying attention to me
because of what I did on
YouTube focused on Twitter
and Facebook pages and were successful.
Because I didn't yell about
Instagram as much 'cause I was
very head down on Vayner.
That was probably the
one, it happened so fast.
It happened so fast, it didn't even--
You know what's funny?
I know you asked me right
before we went on you want to
do something about Peach, I do.
It's the rea-- like, Instagram
happened so fast that I
didn't have time to let
it go mainstream and then
talk about it.
So, why now?
'Cause it's the moment, my moment.
And my moment is defined as
the attention graph moment
which is the moment one
year before something goes
completely mainstream or I
think something's big enough
to really land grab and I'm
not guessing and I'm not
wasting my time.
Which is what a lot of people ask me.
They're like, "How do
you not waste your time?"
Easy, because I'm tasting
like Peach and MusicAlly,
but I'm not all in.
It's funny, a lot of you
are like, "Why's he s--"
I hear a lot of people saying,
"Is Snapchat paying Gary?"
Oh Gary invested in Snapchat a year ago.
Guys, I care about my
personal brand and being right
more than anything.
More than anything in the world.
It's how I will make all my money.
There's no transaction that
will trump me being this
right historically.
Show me that ghost,
Staphon, grab me the ghost.
I mean, what episode was this ghost on?
Like 100 episodes ago.
Like, this isn't like today.
This isn't like, this has
been watching carefully,
calculating.
What do you think, all
this is like by accident?
You think I got (censored) lucky?
You think it's this?
You think I'm throwing
random shit on the table?
You think I'm predicting
Peach is gonna be number one
and then hoping three years from--
No.
It is an understanding, it
is a talent of understanding
when things are on the dawn
of compete main street-ality.
And so, I'm loud now
because I'm gonna end up
being right.
Geeze.
Some serious (censored) silence.
(humming)
Such a good song, right?
- [India] So good.
- I like deep songs, India.
- Really?
- Yeah, you'd be surprised right?
You'd think of me like a bubble pop,
sugar pop mainstream, right?
- Probably has to do with
how many times you listened
to Wrecking Ball, yeah.
- Yeah exactly.
- That's pretty deep
though, too, actually.
- Yeah, Miley's way deeper than you think.
Yeah.
Deeper than you think.
But I like deep songs that
new culture nerds believe
is deep, too.
- Wow. I'm a culture nerd.
Adding that to my Twitter bio.
- That's anybody who really
listens to the music.
Like, people that hate
when things sell out.
You're like the person who
hates when things sell out.
- I don't care, make your money.
- Nice, you're right.
I agree with that, actually
I do know that about you,
I was trying to peg you.
That was unfair of me.
You're a super sell out chick.
- Not as much as Stunwin.
- Yeah right.
Who's that?
- Alright, from Arif.
- [Voiceover] Arif asks,
"When I'm out of the office,
"even though I have a meeting,
I feel guilty about leaving
"my team in the office.
"I'm scared if my team thinks
that, 'the boss is always
"'playing, having fun, and
always taking a long break
"'at lunch.' Any advice?"
- Easy, Arif, results.
Like, if you're playing around
and having a coffee with
this person and networking
with that person,
or sitting court-side at a
Knicks game and you aren't
working, but you bring somebody
and you make a 10 million
dollar deal, it's called
mother fucking results.
You know, funny thing squashes all,
"The boss doesn't do anything." Results.
So, you know, how to deal with it?
You now, it's funny, it's first wrapping--
You know I grew up in a
world that my dad taught me
and I executed in the first
10 years of my career that was
predicated on being at the store
meant you were bringing value.
And so, I get it.
I actually get that question hardcore.
I barely ever left Wine
Library in the first 10 years
of my career.
I was in the same god damn
place every day Monday through
Saturday every single day for
like 10 years from like nine--
I was super locatable.
So I get it.
And you know what? It was a mistake.
I should've took more
trips to wine country,
I should've knocked on
more doors and done B to B
and sold 100 cases at a pop
to corporations in New Jersey.
I should've got out and about.
And so, you know, if you're
the kind of boss that goes
to off sites and zen
thinking and parties at night
and your business goes
down, then people feel like
you didn't deliver.
So, you can get away with
anything if you drive results.
I don't think anybody at Vayner
questions me being around
or not being around
because of the results.
And so, that's it.
I mean, you know, the score
is the score, you know?
It does matter how you get there.
Cheating, doing the wrong
things, the moral compass
matters, but if you're able
to do things on the up and up
then the score is the score.
- [Voiceover] Atiyya asks, "Is
is a beautiful interruption
"in your consumer's day a
good thing or should it be
"seamless?"
- Excuse me?
- [India] Like a beautiful interruption.
If it interrupts you, but
it's enjoyable is it good
or should everything be
seamless in the consumer's--
- It's good because you said
something very interesting
there, India, in your interpretation.
You said the word enjoyable.
Guys, there's only value.
Seamless and interruption
isn't the game, it's value.
If one perceives it as
valuable, then it's a win.
If the greatest looking in
the girl and the girl that
Tyler loves the most in the
world jumped into this office
while he was in the middle
of something and kissed him
on the lips, he would be
happy with that interruption.
On the other hand, if I punched
him in his face and broke
his tooth, that would
be a bad interruption.
That didn't bring a
value, the other one did.
It's value, it's not
interruption, it's not seamless,
it's not these marketing
jargon terms, it's value.
And so, if something--
You said, enjoyable.
Enjoyable is a value.
And so, it's value, so if
you're able to bring value,
if somebody runs three minutes
late to a meeting because
you blocked the road on
the way to their meeting,
which is bad.
Time is the asset, I always say.
But if they valued what
happened in those three minutes
more than the three minutes
they lost in the meeting.
For example, if that street
was littered with rare Jets
jerseys and they were free and I got them,
I'd be okay with being three
minutes late 'cause I value
that more.
If that street was littered
with Misha performing
a five minute play on the
street, I value that more than
being three minutes late.
If it was DRock asking me a
stupid question, I'd be upset.
Even though I love DRock,
the execution of that wasn't
as good.
So, the answer is, yes,
I think, to the question,
which is you can interrupt
people all day long.
You know, when I talk about
marketing, I talk about
value much more than
seamless or interruption.
That trumps everything.
And it's perceived value
by that individual.
It's not what you as a
business think is valuable.
Oh, everybody's gonna love
this because you want them
to love it because you
want to sell it to them.
And some people value something
that other people don't.
So, that's just how that works out.
The market decides.
- [India] Um, from Dennis.
- That's a very weird vibe.
- [Tyler] What's your code?
- 5555, 'cause everybody
knows because DRock doesn't
do a good job editing the
DailyVee and exposes things
like my room number and my
pass code in one episode.
- [DRock] Your room
number was not on there.
- Yes it was, somebody DM'd me it.
Yeah it was.
You didn't know about it
'cause I didn't want to hurt
your feeling, but that's
why everybody knows so I'm
thrilled to put it out on 004
and the AskGaryVee Show.
I was just saying it's a weird mood show.
- Really, I'm having fun.
- Makes sense.
(laughter)
- From Deniz, but it's spelled weird.
This whole episode is weird
names, maybe that's why.
- Don't judge peo-- your name is India.
- No, I think he's trying
to make it a thing.
- No, he probably isn't
from America, India.
It's not just an American world.
I mean, there's other people in the world.
Deniz, it's cool, maybe
his parents are hippies.
- Denise, it looks like
it should be Denise.
- Dennis.
- [Voiceover] Deniz asks,
"What do you think of the new
"emerging social media Peach?
"A fad or something revolutionary?"
- I have no idea.
But I do know this, Dom, who
him and his team created Vine
is an extremely talented product person.
I've been flirting with it,
I've been tasting the Peach
a little bit.
You like that one, Staphon?
I know how you roll.
You know what's so weird?
I literally did that just for you.
- [Staphon] Oh, thank you.
- That was a one audience
value prop statement.
And I'm not ready to say that
it's gonna be here forever,
this and that.
Clearly it's a beautiful
product, clearly the early tech
nerds have fallen in love with
it and are playing with it.
It's got my attention, but
very little right now because
I'm in complete Snapchat storm.
There's only so many hours in the day.
But I'm gonna flirt with it
over the next couple of weeks,
months, watch consumer
behavior, see if it's sticky.
There's been plenty of apps
that have come out in the
tech world with enormous
fan fare that have had 20,
60, 90.
So is it gonna be Plurk?
Which is something a lot of
you don't remember from 2008.
Is it gonna be Daily Booth?
Which AJ and I thought was
gonna be the biggest thing
every, big call by AJ was right.
Basically became Instagram,
but it didn't win.
Or is it gonna become
Instagram or Snapchat?
So, I don't know.
I'm excited about it.
I think chat apps still
have a lot of room,
especially something like this.
But Path had a lot of users,
I was an early investor,
I believed in that product,
that was revolutionary.
But it's not here
anymore, didn't fully win.
And so, you know, it's an exciting thing.
I like watching new trends.
I do think, Staphon, you
should edit in the corner here
while I'm talking about peach,
I've got to assume there's
a video on YouTube already,
this is what Peach looks like
and things of that nature.
So, I guess you can edit that or rip it,
I don't give a shit.
That's it.
So that's, by the way, to
bring value in this show and
not just--
Like, to bring real value into the show,
that's what I tend to do.
I tend to parallel path.
I'm always using a squeezing
the orange to my hardest
on the things that I think
have crossed over the hill
and have become mainstream
items for me and I believe in.
You know, Instagram,
Facebook, now Snapchat.
Right? That's what I'm doing over here.
And there's always a three
to 12 percent of my energies
being deployed to the
MusicAlly's and the Peaches
and the Kiks of the
world to just keep an eye.
'Cause, by the way, that's
what I was doing with Snapchat.
Like, I was watching.
I've been watching all along.
Like, you know?
I've been watching.
Watching.
I'm still watching Pintrest,
four years later now,
to like, when is that
moment gonna cross over
that it's not just heavy
female shopping aspirational?
Is it gonna cross over male?
Is it gonna cross over for
marketers where I can put
info-graphics?
Right? LinkedIn.
I was watching it, then
that content thing happened
and influencers a year and
a half ago and I jumped.
Then they diluted it with
Pulse and I jumped back.
It's a marketplace of
attention, my friends.
There is no, you know, this
is what I said six years ago.
I don't give a shit what
I said six years ago,
it was six years ago!
I don't care what I said
six (censored) minutes ago!
It is a living and breathing
marketplace of attention
that I execute against.
That's why I have success
because I've been good
at judging the right things
to be on with my time and
energy and because I take
the time to listen and watch
consumers on it and then
cultivate a content strategy
that actually brings people
value for the attention
they deploy against me.
And that was a good (censored)
way to wrap up the show because
it took all the themes in
the show in one little rant
at the end.
Question of the day.
Question of the day, what's
your early read on Peach?
Have you even heard of
it prior to this episode?
And if not, how quickly
did you download it?
You keep asking questions,
I'll keep answering them.
(hip hop music)